foreign
[Music]
okay we have white against an 1890 we
did play the jibaba London uh in one
game that's up on YouTube but now we're
back to the official recommendations E4
E5
so when we were like 14 1500 we were
playing
mostly the Vienna just to remind you my
two major recommendations for beginner
and intermediate players are the Vienna
which goes Knight C3 Knight F6 and F4 as
well as the four night Scotch which is
Knight F3 Knight C6 Knight C3 Knight F6
that's the four four nights and then the
scotch part consists of the move d4
so I'm basically eeny meeny miny mowing
it
um
let me think about what I want to play
in this particular game you could play
the Vienna obviously the Vienna loses
some of its luster at a higher level
because people know the theory and most
people don't fall for some of the basic
traps that can give way to winning
position so let's go for our other big
weapon and let's go for night scotch
don't remember if we've had a fortnite
scotch game in this Speed Run you can
probably look that up pretty easily but
that doesn't really matter
so of course in this position black is
not obligated to play Knight F6 but the
other moves contain pretty serious
drawbacks okay F5 is a move that I've
seen tangentially but never really
analyzed this is the Deferred Latvian
Gambit so the Latvian Gambit which we
actually just talked about for those
watching on YouTube Latvian gamut came
up in one of our discussions after
Knight F3 F5 signifies the traditional
Latvian Gambit the insertion of the
moves Knight C6 Knight C3 changes the
nature of the position because Knight
takes C5 is no longer possible and in
response to F5 White's main weapon is
Knight takes C5 the live band Gambit is
essentially refuted here the E5 Pawn is
protected now what is generally the
approach when we when we meet moves like
F5 Right Moves Like F5 are often
considered on sound because they make
permanent and tremendous weaknesses on
the king side and generally the best way
to exploit that is to open up the center
so I think a lot of people when seeing
this move for the first time would be
tempted to play a move like D3 which was
of course Very passive it closes the
bishop and it justifies black setup
after D3 Knight F6
black gets a great position so of course
we can't accept the Gambit with e takes
F5 but that affords black a valuable
Tempo that they can use for development
for example Knight F6 and of course it
also justifies the move F5 you can
almost think of it as a reverse king's
Gambit where taking this Pawn isn't
quite as good when the White Queen
doesn't have a path to H5 and we can't
support the pawn with G4 because the
Knight on F3 blocks the Queen's access
to these two squares so what I'm getting
at is that there's only one move which
is calling my name in this position and
it should be calling your name as well
and you should be playing it really
without all that much calculation
because there really isn't that much to
calculate this move does not come with a
big risk tag right you play D4 we're not
sacrificing anything we are tearing the
center apart in order to open up Avenues
toward to get to Black's King
it might seem like this move is very
complicated and you need to think about
it but if you break down what's actually
happening in the center you'll see that
it's pretty simple to follow he takes D4
we just play Knight takes D4 black can
take twice on D4 but then our Queen
comes out and the Queen on D4 is going
to be a monster if black takes the other
Pawn F takes E4 that's a little bit
trickier there we have to be careful
because if we recapture on e4 then we
allow black to move D5 with Tempo and
black can drive a wedge into the center
with E4 so in response to F takes E4 we
should actually then take the pawn on E5
offering a nitrate
and in the resulting position not only
is Black's King in Mortal danger but we
also have a big development advantage
and black will just have a hard time
keeping the E4 Pawn protected this is
going to be really really fun I'm
looking forward to this and it's pretty
encouraging that our opponent is taking
his time because that means this isn't
some deep Gambit preparation
but hopefully you're able to understand
the logical underpinnings of the move T4
and you're able to see that this move
can be played largely on the basis of
intuition what am I expecting black to
do here I think our opponent is likely
to play e takes D4
is black lost out of the opening here
actually the answer to that question
might be yes from a practical
perspective handling the resulting
complications when the king is as weak
as it is
is virtually impossible I think white is
probably already borderline winning
barring some sort of computer play
yeah not GG just yet
I'm very curious how our opponent
responds to this move
it's crazy that four moves in this much
could already could already be happening
right the move F5 is just so incredibly
damaging because it opens up so many new
Pathways to the black king queen H5 will
always come with check if we bring the
bishop out to C4 the king is not going
to be able to Castle those are the two
main drawbacks of pushing the F Pawn
this early in the opening okay so e
takes D4 of course we play Knight takes
D4
note that in response to Knight takes
Knight we shouldn't give a check on H5
this check is not currently all that
dangerous because it can be blocked with
G6 and your mental reference should be
okay if there's a knight let's say on E5
or H4 then G6 can be met with Knight
takes G6 and That's a classic trick that
hopefully you've seen in puzzle rushes
and uh in different kinds of puzzles
even if you're a beginner here Queen H5
is not an immediate threat if it was our
move well obviously the F5 Pawn is
currently hanging but assuming it wasn't
our next move would be Bishop C4 and
then castles and hopefully the e-file
opens just in time for us to put a rook
on E1 the most important factor is going
to be preventing black from castling
kingside we have to do whatever it takes
to prevent black from Castle in kingside
okay this is a very juicy position so
again the instinct is is to just
recapture on e4 but when you're trying
to punish a Gambit or an unsound opening
you have to think very concretely and
you always have to play for maximum so
just meekly recapturing a pawn without
considering the Alternatives is the best
way to justify the Gambit uh or the
unsound line
and there is one trick that I'm spotting
here which I think comes very close to
winning this game for white right off
the bat now if you know anything about
openings that involve an early push of
the F Pawn for example there's the
Damiano which might be the most famous
of these unsound defenses it's F6 in
this position who can tell me what the
classic refutation is to the move F6
this is a move everybody should know
it's actually not the only way to refute
F6 but it's the most famous you
sacrifice the Knight on E5 and in
response to F take C5 you deliver a
check on H5 now didn't I just say that
the check isn't dangerous well there's
another circumstance under which Quinn
H5 wins the game and that is if you can
take on E5 not only is that a check that
Forks The Rook in the corner Queen picks
up the rook and then the queen easily
gets out of the corner because black
doesn't have the Machinery to attack it
with I'll show this in some depth after
the game what similarity can we extract
from the Damiano well the only big
similarity is that the F Pawn has moved
out of its initial Square allowing us to
check on H5 but there is a second
similarity which is that the E5 square
is now accessible to the White Queen
Once the F F Pawn has moved out of F5
not immediately because the Knight is
guarding that square but we can trade
the Knight so I think Knight takes C6
essentially wins the game as crazy as it
may seem to trade pieces when you're
trying to punish an unsound opening
this is what I meant when I said you
have to think concretely right Knight C6
isn't necessarily A logical move trading
a knight in the center for a night that
has just come out but it's a move based
on concrete considerations black has to
recapture
then we deliver a check on H5 G6 gets
forked okay this doesn't change anything
we still check on H Drive in fact DC I
think is the only way for black to stay
alive for longer than a couple of moves
yeah this is what black has to do king
E7 obviously our opening strategy has
resulted in success but it's important
not to rest on our Laurels we're
actually winning these types of
positions where you have what seems to
be a decisive development Adventure can
be a lot harder and more frustrating
than it appears so don't think that our
job is already done and everything wins
that could not be further from the truth
First Things First bishop G5 does not
win the queen because black brings the
night out to F6 okay so Bishop G5 check
might be a good move but we shouldn't
hope to win the queen of that move now
after Knight F6 I I see the move Knight
takes E4 using the pin against the
Knight and putting more pressure on the
Knight so that's one way to play we of
course can still give the check on E5
that'll probably Force black to play
Bishop E6 because the moment the king
moves to F7 the other Bishop comes out
with check and that seems utterly
devastating so let's consider that for a
second Queenie five check Bishop to E6
the bishop is pinned so Bishop C4 comes
to mind in that position but the queen
can come up and protect the bishop
simultaneously offering a queen trade
that is the last thing that we want here
Queen trade unless it is accompanied by
let's say material gain of some sort
okay so let me think about this for just
a couple more seconds
I have a pretty cool idea in mind I'm
just verifying that it's as good as it
looks
I really think it is
I think it is
okay
so here's how
I propose that we continue I still like
the move Bishop G5 check for starters
um I also like Queen E5 check I think
there are multiple ways to reach a
decisive Advantage even the simple
Knight takes E4 I talked about this a
couple of games ago uh when we had a
comparable attack I think it came from
an elephant where oftentimes there's a
Temptation over complicate and start
calculating long lines whereas a very
simple move like Knight takes E4 keeps
all of the advantages of the position it
restores material equality and it gets a
knight to the center so if you're
struggling and you're not finding
anything resorting to simple moves such
as a recapture or a developing move can
be an easy way to maintain the pressure
so I'd like to start either with Bishop
G5 check or with Bishop C4 I don't
actually think it matters
yeah let's start
hmm let me think about this
okay let's go Bishop C4
so we're bringing out the light squared
Bishop
we're threatening immediate Checkmate on
F7
and I am hoping for the move Queen to E8
this is what I'm expecting
why am I expecting Queen E8 well black
somehow has to defend the F7 Square
we've already established the G6 never
works because of Queen E5 check at the
very least picking up the rook in the
corner
Knight G8 to H6
walks into Bishop G5 and black has
nothing to block the pin with
the only other move that I see here is
Bishop C8 to E6 intercepting our Bishop
but I didn't take that move too
seriously maybe I should have
but I figured even if we trade on E6
that brings the black king out even tune
to an even more vulnerable spot and in
that resulting position again we can
play it simple we can play Knight takes
E4
for goodness sake and then the Knight
jumps into G5 that has to be devastating
the greatest thing about playing this
position is that we're not down material
it's not like we've sacrificed anything
to reach this position and that is why
you can allow yourself to play in
simpler ways than you would have been
able to if you were down a piece right
now and you really had something to
prove here you can just kind of chill
out and play simple moves and worse
comes to worse okay your opponent
consolidates you reset and you continue
attacking let's take on E6 we're playing
this like a Russian School by trading
off one of Black's only Defenders now
the king is all alone but we don't have
the Machinery to exploit the king
position yet we all we have is our Queen
currently in the attack we can give
let's say a check on G4 but that's
counterproductive because it sends the
king back to safety on F7 the queen is
very well placed here because it's
blocking off the king's Escape back to
F7 back to the king side
let's play Knight takes C4
why didn't I instead develop the bishop
because I was worried about Knight G8 to
F6 and once the queen is knocked off of
H5 the king can drop back to F7 and once
it reaches F7 black comes very close to
consolidating all black will have to do
then is bring their Bishop out move the
rook and kind of manually Castle the
king will eventually reach the promised
land on G8 so that's what we have to
avoid at all costs and that's why I took
on e4 I'm threatening to deliver a check
on G5
forcing the king in the other direction
which is what we want if we can force
the king onto the D file hopefully
you're able to see that the Rook on H1
is only one tempo away from joining the
attack I mean we will castle kingside at
some point and then we'll be ready to
play Rook D1 Queen also defends that
square so we can play Rook D1 even if
the black king hasn't blocked the queen
so Knight G5 is one huge threat don't
forget that Knight F7 could be a simple
way to win material regardless of the
king's placement
of course black could make a Mad Dash
for the queen side King D7 castles King
C8 but once the king reaches C8 it
doesn't you know Black's problems aren't
solved there and I think we can still
get to the king if it's on the queen
side
if he goes
ski eight well obviously then we avoid
the queen trade
I'd have to think about it Queenie it is
probably Black's best move
I think we can deliver a check on G4 in
that case
and that contradicts what I just said it
allows the king to move back to F7 we
really have no choice in that situation
but the caveat as that after we Castle
our Knight still is able to jump into G5
so the King on F7 isn't fully safe if
we're able to deliver the check on G5
and I'll show some of those lines after
the game Queen D5 is definitely a good
move it's a good defensive move
now we rule out Queen takes D5 Chuck the
obvious move I think is Knight to G5
check
that forces the king back toward a D7 or
E7 and in all cases
I think the king doesn't reach safety
because there's always these diagonal
checks that we can deliver if the king
moves to D7 if the king moves to E7 then
will most certainly castle and put a
rook on E1 and continue shepherding the
king toward the most dangerous part of
the board which is the D file
um
I don't see a reason for us to dilly
dally I think we should give this check
promptly
not over I mean our opponent is
defending resiliently
and if you play an engine in a position
like this you're gonna lose like 99
times out of 100 because actually
finishing someone off who's defending
super accurately Hikaru does this too
you can feel like you're mating him 10
different ways but checkmating the king
in an open board when the king is stuck
in the center like this is incredibly
hard because the King has so many
directions that it can escape to and the
center is open which means that there's
a high probability and possibility of
Trades so you got to manage all of that
load and hunt the king at the same time
with limited material that's hard so
don't feel like the Checkmate in these
types of King hunts is easy or you're
missing something obvious if you don't
see something convincing so we're
waiting for our opponent to decide where
he wants to put the king
I'm expecting King D7 but the best move
is probably King to E7 in both cases I
think we're just gonna Castle short
without too much of a thought
without a second thought I should say
we've already put in some thought
man this is this is completely winning
no doubt about it
but a couple more precise moves are
required
I think some people watching this thus
far might be disappointed that we
haven't sacrificed anything we haven't
made any sexy moves so we've just
literally played the most simple moves
on the board we made
a developing move
we made a capture we made a capture and
then we delivered like the most obvious
check and this comes back to the point I
made in that alapan game which
ultimately resulted in Checkmate which
is that I think when you read books on
attacking tactics the art of attack
interests might be misrepresented in
your mind and you might reach the false
idea that every attack somehow
culminates in a combination or must
feature some sort of a sacrifice in fact
90 to 95 of attacks in chess
are attacks of the salt of the earth
variety where you just make a bunch of
simple attacking moves and the Kings
checkmated or you win a decisive amount
of material and it's important to
understand that because then you kind of
know what you're looking for and you
shouldn't shy away from these
straightforward moves thank you chess
dojo for the raid appreciate it not
trying to you know get on the soapbox
here but
I think I know quite a few players who
tend to rule out certain moves because
they're quote unquote too simple or
they're not sacrificial enough there's a
time for sacrifice but that time doesn't
occur as frequently as you might think
when you're attacking
can Magnus hold this position I don't
think so in a classical game I think
this is borderline resignable for black
somebody was proposing King F6 here
doesn't fundamentally change
the fabric of the position I still think
that we should Castle why is it so
important to Castle as king F6 display
because rookie a check is a potential
idea although on second thought that
square is protected so maybe we can use
this Tempo to do something a little bit
smarter I have a second idea that I just
came up with
which is a move I didn't really
appreciate at first but the more I look
at it the more I like it I will admit
that I didn't notice the E8 Square was
defended until just a second ago
so I think a lot of people are
catching my drift here which is that the
bishop would be ideally placed on the
long diagonal and so a lot of people
come up with the move B3 but you really
have to optimize your ideas in this type
of position don't just make the first
execution of the idea that you see try
to weigh its minuses and act on those
minuses to find a different better
execution what is the drawback of B3
well it's not actually a developing move
and it allows black to deliver a very
unpleasant check on B4 then black can
beat white to the punch and stick a
bishop on C3 which prevents us from
playing Bishop B2
so what's the different execution that
I'm speaking of well it's the simple
Bishop to D2 the modest looking Bishop
to D2 we're aiming for C3 once the
bishop reaches C3 I feel like the king
is just busted we force the king back to
the e-file then we can castle and then
once a rook lands on E1 literally every
piece will be joining in the attack
so I don't see any reason for us not to
play Bishop D2 notice that Queen E5
check might be a scary looking move
because it forces White's King to move
but we don't care about that all we need
is one Rook we don't really need both of
our Rooks in the attack so after Queen
E5 King F1
that's not the Rook that we expected
would be jumping in but who cares Rook
A1 to E1 is going to be devastating
Queen F7 will be a mate threat in that
resulting position
I call this thinking in terms of squares
anytime you're attacking a wide open
King like this you at all times have to
be aware of the potential mating
constructions in this case I only really
see one which is Queen F7 but you make a
mental note to yourself that anytime
black screen loses contact with F7
you're going to be aware that Queen F7
becomes a serious idea
I don't see any other mating
constructions of the black king on F6
okay G6 G6
well that doesn't change anything we of
course still play Bishop C3 check and I
think this is going to lead to decisive
material loss imminently
uh note by the way that the discovery
Knight takes H7 check is possible but
clearly inferior
because the king is able to reach G7
black can also sacrifice The Exchange on
H7 and the black queen is defended it's
defended by the C6 spawn so Knight takes
H7 here is ill-advised and it certainly
does not win the queen of course we play
Bishop C3 check anyway forcing the king
toward the center
and after the king reaches the center
you should of course also notice that
the Rook on h8 is hanging which might
not seem significant but it is right
when you're attacking you're not just
hunting for checkmate you're also
trying to win a decisive amount of
material that is a totally legitimate
outcome of an attack simplifying and
emerging let's say up a piece or up a
rook in an end game that can be a
practical and simple way to finish off
an attack and convert it into something
tangible
yeah very good Queen E2 Queen E2 check
is going to finish the game once the
king reaches E7 because the king is
going to be forced back to the D file
where we will pick it off well rather
we'll pick the Queen off with Rook to D1
and that is all she wrote
King cannot move to F6 cannot move to F7
okay so there are a couple of
modifications that we can make here but
again let's keep it as simple as
possible of course you should see that
black can play rookie 8. but that's what
I was talking about in that position we
can if we want keep our Queen we can
play Rook takes Queen and then intercept
the e-file with Bishop E5 but there is a
much simpler way to guarantee Victory
after rookiee much simpler who can spot
this sequence of moves the move order
actually doesn't really matter but you
want to try to follow the most clinical
the most forcing move order
yeah you could even play Bishop takes h8
here that is a way to really rub it in
Black's face who the boss is but much
simpler is to First Take the queen then
take the rook and then take the other
Rook or we can immediately play actually
we can immediately Play Bishop takes h8
Rook takes C2 King takes E2 and we are
up a full Rook once you see a
continuation like this that you know for
a fact is going to guarantee Victory as
it just did there's really no need for
us to search for anything else there's
no need for us to calculate a move like
Bishop E5 maybe black has this this is
exactly how you butcher these types of
games uh you try to get too fancy uh and
you try to Checkmate rather than
make the most practical conversion of
the attack
that was nice it was a simple game but
it really illustrates how bad the move
F5 is like across most openings with the
exception of course of the Dutch but the
reason F5 here is Justified is because
this diagonal is closed and this
diagonal is closed right white hasn't
moved the E Pawn yet
so it really changes the dynamic of the
game although F5 is a pretty dubious
opening even against one D4 you have to
know a lot of very tactical lines like
the Staunton Gambit with E4 is nothing
to sneeze at
and this can get very very dicey for
black if you don't know all of the
theory
so let's have a look at how bad exactly
how bad the move F5 here is
so we respond with D4 hopefully the
logic behind this move was clear enough
really really quickly I was referencing
the Damiano which is F6 there is a
fascinating story between why the
damiano's called what it is called right
you might say well what kind of an idiot
was Damiano to advocate for a move like
F6 which even if it's the year is 1400
or 1500 which is when Damiano lived and
opening Theory isn't well developed just
using first principles it's obvious that
F6 is a very bad move you're blocking
the knights normal developing Square
you're opening up a diagonal you're
weakening the king side permanently so
it's obviously a bad move and even D4
leads to an almost decisive Advantage
for a wife but Knight takes E5 is the
famous refutation it's been known for
hundreds of years really since the 1500s
and it is followed by Queen H5 check
forking the king and the pawn one fork
turns into another if black plays G6 we
win The Rook in the corner it's
important to point out that in this
position black cannot play Bishop G7 on
the next move because of the pin against
the bishop so I think the simplest is to
play D3 and essentially to pre-move
Bishop G5 which pins and potentially
wins the Knight black loses all of his
freaking pieces or you can even play
Bishop to H6 if you want to keep it
simple and then simplify by taking on f8
with the queen and forcing a queen trade
white is up in exchange and a pawn in
the resulting end game there are many
ways to win you can analyze this with an
engine if you want to be very diligent
you can also play Knight C3
okay so G6 loses and King E7 loses an
even more spectacular fashion because
the King has driven to the edge of the
Earth with a series of checks and King
G6 gets checkmated in very famous style
this is a very famous line again it's
been known for centuries check
now I discovered check with a pawn and
now the classic right you can see the
Rook you can see the king they are
x-raying each other so H4 is a very
thematic mating move you're threatening
HG and queen F7 it's mate and nine
according to the engine if black gives
up like all of his pieces so white can
play Bishop takes G5 or HG there's
nothing left to analyze
technically it is more resilient to play
D5 with the idea of protecting the F5
square with the bishop and here white
has many ways to win but there's a very
beautiful line that also has been known
for many centuries it starts with H4 so
you're threatening to play H5 followed
by a discovery with D4 forcing black to
make some Luft and now there is a
beautiful move that ends the game on the
spot it wins a decisive amount of
material who knows what this move is
and by the way the same move would
follow after H5 it would come with even
greater effect
it's Bishop takes B7 yeah this is worth
knowing this is worth knowing it's a
deflection sacrifice but it's not really
a sacrifice because this is Checkmate
and in the events of H5 this just takes
a couple moves longer here here and the
clinical move here is actually Queen to
F7 threatening HG and Rook takes H5
which will be made
so this is definitely worth remembering
what else is there to say I guess black
has Bishop D6 but as long as we maintain
contact with the F5 Square this move
doesn't change anything Queen to A5 is
the computer move which evades any
further attacks on the queen black and
play Knight C6 but then we take C6 we're
up two pawns and the Raging attack
against the king continues so uh this is
really all you have to know H4 followed
by Bishop takes B7 now someone was
asking what happens if black doesn't
take the Knight yes the best move for
black here is the pathetic Queen E7 and
this does win the pawn back you just
drop your knight back but if black takes
look at the development advantage that
white has I was gonna say develop an
advantage that white is developed
White's gonna go Knight C3 castles put
something on E1 such as a rook and
Black's can't queen is going to get
absolutely massacred this is plus three
according to the computer you can
analyze this further on your own it's
been tried by some good players but
black is just dead lost here dead lost
for example let's say black plays Knight
C6 I would actually Castle right I
wouldn't rush with Knight C3 because the
black queen is a great asset for white
if you play rookie one either you win
the queen or you can deliver a
devastating discover check against the
queen if the queen drops back there's a
bunch of cool moves you can even play
Knight to E5 chiguran actually fell for
a trick like this uh the one time that
he tried the Damiano
and you lose the queen so wherever you
look there are sexy tactics and this is
really not worthy of analysis but before
we move to the game continuation the
hilarious story behind why the Damiano
is called is named after Damiano
it has to do with Rue Lopez not the
opening but the man himself Roy Lopez
was a priest from Spain who lived in the
16th century he wrote one of the first
books on chess where he examined some
openings including the one that's named
after him but a little known fact is
that Rue Lopez was actually the first
person to he I think he invented a
couple of other openings he definitely
considered the Italian but believed that
Bishop B5 was a better move that's why
we name it Laurie Lopez he might have
been the originator also of like the
ponciani and a couple of other openings
so his manuscript was really
groundbreaking for the time the funny
thing is that he had a feud with Damiano
I've talked about this on stream before
he had a flat out
um Feud with Damiano who lived before
him and published a manuscript before re
Lopez which apparently rolopez was
jealous about so rule up is falsely
attributed the move F6 to Damiano and
basically called it the Damiano game
kind of as a troll right sarcastically
and it has stuck ever since right so
it's we think it's named after someone
who advocated for this move but Damiano
was actually the first one to refute F6
he understood that F6 was bad he gave
the reputation in his book and yet we
still call it that I have the actual
evidence for that and the historical
underpinnings of this in a book that I
have but uh if I would rifle through it
right now this YouTube video would take
two hours so I'll save that for another
video
I'll save that for another video
okay so on we go to the game
continuation Knight C3 F5 T4 okay he
takes D4 I think makes things even worse
because it helps us open the center
Black's position here is in Dire Straits
according to the engine F takes E4 is
the only way to say to stay alive more
or less Knight takes E5 and Knight F6
here black is
oh no black is actually busted because
of a really cool line so apparently
white is supposed to go here
which looks rather
dumb because of D5 but black is so
poorly developed that almost any
sacrifices are going to be strong here
so for example Knight takes D5 is the
engine move sacrificing a knight in
order to pave the way for a check on H5
now what did I talk about during the
game
anytime there's a knight on one of these
three squares G6 is innocuous because if
Knight takes G6 and what's funny is that
here you don't take the Rook you
actually take the pawn you take the pawn
if the king steps up to E7
you skewer the queen
so King D7 is forced and Bishop takes D5
leads to clearly a decisive attack now
this is stockfish 11 that I'm using on
on chess.com you should probably confirm
this with stronger engine but it gives
plus four and I don't see any reason to
doubt its evaluation why it's
threatening Checkmate in one
let's say Knight 64. now the other
Bishop comes out Bishop East oh now a
sexy Bishop E6 check
is winning either black has to step into
a discovery or like us to step into a
skewer
and the bishop is pinned so black can't
block the check
here you can even gobble up the pawn
first and only now you can take the
queen
Bishop E3 check White's got three
additional pawns C5 B4 with a decisive
attack on the King which has been driven
all the way to the queen side which I
always kind of like
um
wow that is a pretty juicy line
so where did that come from yeah so F
takes C4 and Knight F6 is more logical
to me here Bishop C4 is incredibly
strong it threatens Knight F7 so Black's
hand is essentially forced here Knight
takes D5 and if Knight takes E5 then of
course we just recapture and now the
queen defends the Knight
would even play like a Russian Schoolboy
and take back with a queen take back
with the bishop so these lines are
pretty one-sided but they're always very
fun to look at because they really
demonstrate the the importance of
developing your pieces and the disaster
that that waits for for he who you know
who pushes his F Pawn too early
now you might be listening to this and
saying well wait a second I learned that
in Marie Lopez Knight F3 Knight C6
Bishop B5 there is a variation called
the schliemann where black plays F5 you
might have also learned from someone
like Eric Rosen that F5 is a possible
move even after white plays Bishop C4
even in the Italian
and how do you marry those that with
what I just said is F5 a losing line is
the schliemann refuted no the schliemann
is not refuted white is considered to be
better in the schliemann actually the
best move ironically is D3 which is the
move that I criticized in the context of
our game but you have to remember that
these things I say are very concretely
tied into the position the bishop on B5
is not ideally placed in the context of
punishing black from playing F5 because
it's not controlling the a2ga diagonal
which means black is going to have an
easier time castling
and if you play D4 in this position
the placement of the of the white Bishop
gives black a very important Tempo so
here fe4 95 95 D5 this position could
have occurred in our game with the
difference that there was a knight on C3
and the bishop was still on F1 who can
tell me how black can exploit the very
awkward placement of the bishop to win
material and get out of the gates with
an advantage actually black is better in
this line
C6 yeah like play C6 okay you might say
doesn't that send the bishop to where it
wants to go anyway
well no if you look carefully this Pawn
is undefended the king is only one Queen
A5 check is a fork and even though white
has a development Advantage black will
connect the pawns with D5
and why can white is actually lost after
D5 simply lost because this Pawn chain
is impregnable and black is going to
start getting his pieces out
subsequently
and black will not have a hard time
castling
I might say okay I get it but what about
it in the Italian is F5 uh possibly a
move that black can get away with here
and the answer is yes and no F5 is a
borderline losing line and I will have a
YouTube video refuting it because I know
it's a popular subject of some YouTube
videos the best move here is in fact to
play D4 much like we did in the game
but after e takes D4 the chief
difference is that if white plays Knight
takes D4 Kindle like we did in the game
I don't know what the mainline theory is
but I think the black move here is
Knight F6 I'm pretty sure this is the
recommended move and there's a very
important concrete detail the placement
of the bishop on C4 is actually a
drawback in this case why because black
has the move D5 hitting the bishop with
tempo and obviously the idea is to
undermine the E4 plot so this is one of
the lines which is often featured in
overviews of this variation ed5 Bishop
F5 white does not lose a piece because
white recaptures but in the ensuing end
game black gets a huge initiative and
this is exactly what the kind of
position the Gambit players want white
might still be slightly better but
clearly we've gone astray
now compare this to the situation after
Knight C3 F5 D4 if black plays Knight F6
here which probably he should still have
done I actually think this might be
Black's best move just sacrificing the
pawn in order to get better development
the move D5 it doesn't come with Tempo
it doesn't attack the bishop so I
actually think that white could ignore
everything that's happening in the
center and play a move like Bishop B5 to
pin the Knight
and if black plays Pawn takes Pawn yes
black wins the pawn back but look at how
crappy this end game is for black now
Black's King is the one that's lost
castling writes E4 is weak and white can
calmly Castle kingside on the next move
I know this is a lot of theory but I'm
really I'm trying to give you the kind
of foundation for the things that I say
and to make realize that really the
importance of studying opening say this
is going to be one of the key takeaways
from this little analysis session
because you can really see that making
General statements about what's good and
what's not in the opening is possible to
a degree I mean you know the developing
your pieces is good pushing pawns from
the corners is bad but even that isn't
always true one thing that's true with
the bishop on C4 can be false with the
bishop on B5 and vice versa but you
definitely should not push your F Pawn
with black unless you're specifically
aware that it's a legitimate opening
that you've studied the theory
uh so anyways I think Bishop B5 here is
very strong and if black trades on F5
then white gets the bishop pair as well
as an extra Pawn but at least here black
is able to castle at least here black is
able to bring his Bishop out and to
Castle short and the game continues this
E6 Square by the way could be used as an
outpost potentially for White's Rock so
I like rookie1 here the engine gives
about plus 1.5 which I think is a
reasonable assessment
anyways
I know that was a lot I think that our
opponents move Fe this is obviously the
decisive mistake and after Knight C6 and
queen H5 the game basically ends again
how did I see that quickly well I'm
aware of this idea Queen H5 Queen E5
from the Damiano
and of course we're also aware that you
can take on C6 whenever you want to and
that relinquishes Black's control over
the E5 Square so F take C4 is the losing
move and Knight takes C6 is the way to
punish it notice that we didn't just
automatically grab on e4 as a matter of
fact Knight takes E4 believe it or not
is a losing move Knight C3 takes E4
loses the game maybe this is what our
opponent was hoping for who can tell me
why Knight takes C4 loses material and
you should see this in just a couple of
seconds because there's tension between
one pair of knights that means the White
Queen is tied down to the D4 right and
the simple Queen E7 wins a piece because
the standard response doesn't work
anymore you lose the Knight
and if you play F3 you run into D5 and
you'll lose the piece that way you can
try Bishop G5
but black can play Knight F6 and
ultimately You're Gonna Lose the 94. so
this shows you when you're facing an
unorthodox opening
an opening that you think is unsound the
first step is to kind of generally try
to tell yourself why you think is unsaid
what exactly is its main drawback in
this case by specifically identifying
its drawback which is that it a weakens
this diagonal and B after Bishop C4
weakens this other diagonal I was able
to more efficiently zero in on the best
way to refute this opening first we know
that we want to open up the center and
then second we know that Queen H5 Queen
E5 is often the way to punish openings
that involve an early F5 or F6 okay so
once again I think Knight to F6 was
blacks really Black's only chance to to
stay in the game of course Knight takes
D4 was probably also uh better than what
our opponent did in the game maybe Queen
F6 here is an attempt to exchange Queens
but of course we wouldn't have agreed we
would have played E5 driving the pawn in
preventing black snide from developing
to F6 and this is just a hot mess I mean
19 five hitting the pawn and you can
kind of dig around here on your own I
think this will teach you a lot about
how to play against such openings but I
don't want to bug you down too much
let's take a quick look at how the game
proceeded so Knight C6 DC I don't think
it even matters Which Way black takes
the variations are very similar
there's just one critical tactical
detail that I had to foresee now when I
was making this move this is really
really cool so who could tell me a
sequence of moves that seems to win the
game almost on the spot a la Damiano
like this is the same sequence that we
had in the Damiano with one critical
exception the black pawn is now on C6
rather than B7
so what comes to mind here yeah the best
move is Knight D5 check which is
ridiculous but how do we get to Knight
C5 check well first you should see Queen
E5 check again folks Bishop G5 does not
win the queen if you're newer to chess
don't assume that every skewer wins
meteorg you can block a check here Black
Blocks the check with Knight F6 and
white is still winning I think after 94.
but Queen E5 King F7 and Bishop C4 is
exactly how we proceed in the Damiano
King G6 gets checkmated it's actually
made in three after Queen takes E4
okay but black as the move D5 but
hopefully you're able to see that the
king and Rook are on four couple squares
and white has the very straightforward
Knight takes D5 but here is the twist if
black plays CD then Bishop takes D5 just
ends the game it's actually not even
about The Rook so much that it is about
the fact that White's King is checkmated
the engine gives Maiden 9 here that
starts with queen G3 check but clearly
wherever the King goes it's going to get
Chuck mated one way or the other worse
comes to worse you could just take the
rook and be up a ton of material
but what's the problem here right again
you can never assume in these sharp
positions that your opponent has to
recapture a piece you have to look more
concretely than that and if you do
you'll find that black has this weird
move Bishop B6 getting the bishop out
and somehow White's pieces in the center
are kind of loose you really don't want
to be playing the move Knight E3 because
this gives blacks this gives black a
breather and black can use this breather
to get to quickly get the the king side
pieces out and complete the manual
Castle
so anytime you have a flaw like this in
a sequence you need to consider that
same sequence with a different move
order this is an incredibly powerful
tool switching the move order can
eliminate various defensive resources
and that's why we come up with the
immediate Knight D5 trick same exact
theme but it it does not allow black to
to cover the check with D5 C takes D5 is
forced now we deliver a check like this
a check like this and of course we don't
have our Bishop out so we will have to
satisfy ourselves with Queen takes Rook
but this is obviously completely winning
don't take on e4 first because of Queen
E7 pinning the Queens anytime your king
is in the center and a queen is on the
same file you have to be very careful
Knight D5 is absolutely beautiful yeah
Knight T5 check is the move but
hopefully the logic is understandable
now that I traced it we start with Queen
E5 we see that detail Bishop E6 and we
switch up the move order starting with
Knight T5
okay so yeah BC was more resilient of
course here it's a different situation
because Black's light squared Bishop is
open but on the flip side the light
squares around Black's King are even
weaker with the D7 Pawn gone to C6 so
again if you look at the computer there
will be probably even four or five
different ways to reach a decisive
Advantage I think the the path that we
chose is simple and incredibly strong
it's the second move according to the
engine and I don't want to get too
bogged down in the details here it's
very obvious the black is getting
checkmated again G6 Queen E5 is just
made in two
well we don't even need to win the rock
Knight F6 does not defend against Queen
F7 and I'll let you figure out the rest
what else could black have done I was
expecting Queen E8 originally
and here I was intending well I thought
there were two good moves the first I
thought was Bishop G5 check Knight F6
Bishop takes F6 and then swing the queen
over to C5 forcing the king onto the D
file and now you castle with check I
thought this was a decisive attack but
now that I look at it maybe this is not
as convincing
according to the engine on Queen E8
Queen E5 check is best
King D7
now you give another diagonal check okay
King drops back now you develop the
bishop okay and now whatever black does
you castle with Jack and this is just
absolutely oh look at this line takes
takes and bang using the pin on the
bishop and now in comes the second Rook
with mate to follow
yeah so many cool lines when you've got
this many pieces in the attack you're
always going to get uh you know really
nice tactical details simple but but
very nice
so in this position black has to step
the other way but here you still develop
the bishop of check
and here you deliver another check
forcing the king
to the D file and according to the
engine you're supposed to take on F6
twice attack The Rook Castle Queen side
and I can go on and on here but I'll
just show one more cool detail after
Rook f8 white has a really beautiful
sequence that wins an exchange and of
course with the exchange black soul
position crumbles who can spot this two
move this two mover along the same theme
that the combination we just saw
occurred yeah Bishop E6 check deflection
and queen takes Rook using the pin on
the bishop
so so so many of these lines all all
around yeah so maybe Queen E8 was more
resilient Bishop E6 we take we take and
the game is the game is over the engine
gives around plus five which I think is
a accurate assessment and it keeps
growing the more it looks at this
position
Queen D5 I think is as good of a
defensive attempt as any forcing us to
deliver this check and then I think
Bishop D2 is really the star of the show
also winning would have been the simple
castles kingside but after age six I
wasn't actually all that convinced and I
didn't want to give black the
opportunity to take this Knight and Sack
The Exchange and prolong the game
uh so Bishop D2 is really the cherry on
top it's more important to involve the
bishop than it is to involve the rook
and we note that the E8 square is
defended by the queen that's very very
important Bishop D2 is a quiet but
deadly move black cannot stop Bishop C3
and once again B3 is the flash your
execution but the inferior execution
because of the check on before and the
moment black sticks the bishop on C3
you've actually lost all of your
advantage here with white also you have
to be very careful about the D1 Square
being undefended
so in any case we play Bishop D2 to
preclude that possibility
then we stick the bishop on C3
we give a check on E2 we go rook q1 and
if you look at again if you flip on the
computer the best move is in fact Bishop
E5 which is what I pointed out but this
is where simple execution uh is just
much more practical just take on h8 and
you know for a fact that you can convert
this position because black is no way of
trapping the bishop there's no Pawn to
put on F6 and uh you know I appreciate
that our opponent didn't prolong the
torture and resign in this position so
only 18 moves conceptually a very simple
game which illustrates the importance of
blasting open the center when you have a
big development Advantage when your
opponent has a weak King but hopefully
you also found the sort of theoretical
exposition to be to be helpful I will be
doing a video in the near future on this
opening which I think is called the
Russo Gambit and it's it is problematic
for a lot of players and there's quite a
bit of theory here I have some cool
analysis in this opening
and the refutation starts with D4 e
takes D4 and now actually the move E5
driving the pawn in and preventing the
knight from developing but there's a lot
of stuff here too to break down so I'll
be doing that pretty shortly
F5 against the real Lopez is a totally
legitimate line I played it against
Dominguez in the U.S championship in the
last year and I managed to make a draw
so you can definitely consider the
schliemann as a very interesting way to
spice things up against the re Lopez but
on that note folks I think we'll call it
a day it's really late I'm gonna go to
sleep
I'll see you guys later have a good
night everybody thanks again
[Music]